hallo leute wir sind heute an der virgin
taylor school im nordwesten von london
meldung hat uns eingeladen in seinen
deutschunterricht und zusammen mit den
schülern hier zeigen wir euch heute
besonders häufige reflex sie bewerben im
deutschen los geht's reflexive werben
sind verben in denen sich das subjekt
auf sich selbst bezieht das subjekt und
das objekt sind in diesem fall identisch
ich fühle mich nicht gut sie fühlt sich
nicht gut
laurie erinnert sich nicht wo seine
hausaufgaben sind am morgen nach der
party befindet sich die in der
abstellkammer karte stellt sich immer
total an wenn sie eine spinne sieht die
meisten reflexiven werben werden mit
akkusativ pronomen gebildet mich dich
sich uns euch sich stewart langweilt
sich wenn er das wörterbuch liest
fritz ich möchte etwas sagen aber er
traut sich nicht
wir fühlen uns ein bisschen nervös weil
wir ein video mit easy german machen
so setzt euch bitte himmel sensen und
eddie entschuldigen sich bei einander
alex kann sich nicht entscheiden mit wem
er zur party geht
lori meldet sich nie im unterricht
stewart beschäftigt sich immer mit dem
umweltschutz
manche reflexive werben werden auch mit
dativ pronomen gebildet das pronomen
steht meistens dann im dativ wenn es im
satz bereits ein akkusativ objekt gibt
ich kaufe mir eine kanne kaffee denn ich
bin café süchtig wir ziehen uns unsere
jacken an
ich überlege mehrere eine antwort auf
diese frage
viele werben haben eine reflexive und
eine nicht reflexive form
ich ziehe mich an ich ziehe eine jacke
ich ziehe mir einige
die schüler bewegen den tisch so hat es
auf dem tisch und bewegt sich nicht
der lehrer trennt die schüler in zwei
gruppen
lori und stewart wollen sich nicht
trennen
andere werben haben nur eine reflexive
form
wir freuen uns immer auf die
deutschstunde also jungs ich bin wieder
da wenn herbert den raum verlässt wir
nehmen wir uns dann eben beim lesen
entspanne ich mich immer und jetzt seid
ihr dran hier könnt selbstreflexive
werben üben und zwar in unserer app sie
länger dort könnt ihr mit videos lernen
eure aussprache trainieren und auch
grammatik übungen zu den reflexiven
werben machen und natürlich auch
vokabeln lernen mit unserem
vokabeltrainer probiert das mal aus hier
geht es lang und hier könnt ihr sie
german abonnieren damit ihr jede woche
bescheid wisst wenn ein neues video
kommt muss und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]